Willkommen an der Militärakademie in Wiener
Neustadt. Ich bin Oberst Markus Reisner, der
Leiter der Forschungs- und Entwicklungsabteilung der
Theresianischen Militärakademie und heute wollen
wir Ihnen ein aktuelles Lage-Update zur Schlacht
im Donbass geben - am Tag 135, dem 8. Juli 2022.
Beginnen wir kurz zur Abholung wieder mit einer
Orientierung. In den letzten knapp drei Monaten
war die Masse der Gefechte vor allem im Donbass
zu sehen. Wir haben also auch Angriffe gesehen im
Raum Charkiw bzw. auch bei Cherson, aber
die Intensität der Gefechte hat vor allem
im Donbass in den letzten zwei Monatenvor allem
nicht nachgelassen. Schauen wir uns nun die
letzten drei Monate noch einmal im Detail an.
Beginnen wir mit Anfang April. Anfang April war
die Situation die, dass die russische Seite
die Kräfte aus dem Raum Kiew in den Osten
verschoben hat, im Eisenbahntransport, und dort mit
den Vorbereitungen für die Schlacht um den Donbass
begonnen hat. Die Vorbereitungen waren vor allem
geprägt durch eine Neustrukturierung der Kräfte
und durch das Anwenden einer neuen Taktik,
eingeleitet durch massive Artillerieschläge
und ein langsames Vormarschieren. Am 3. April
verlief die Frontlinie circa 60 Kilometer ostwärts
der beiden Städte Slowjansk und Kramatorsk,
und wenn wir uns die Karte des 3. April
im Vergleich nun zur Karte des 3. Juli,
also vor wenigen Tagen, ansehen, so erkennen
wir den Geländegewinn, den die Russen in diesen
letzten drei Monaten erzielt haben. Und zwar vor
allem nordostwärts und ostwärts von diesen beiden
Städten Slowjansk und Kramatorsk. Sehen wir uns
noch einmal die Ereignisse im Detail von Beginn
an an. Nach circa einem Monat Vorbereitung und
massiven Artillerieangriffen war es am 5. bzw.
6. Mai der Fall, dass bei Popasnaja die
Russen tatsächlich einen Einbruch erzielt haben.
Wesentlich wahrscheinlich deswegen möglich, weil
die ukrainischen Kräfte im Zentrum durch die
wiederholten Einsätze an der Front abgenutztwaren.
Dieser Durchbruch von Popasnaja, von
den Russen "die Blume" genannt, hat sich in den
nächsten Wochen ausgeweitet. Wir sehen das hier
in der Karte gut, im Vergleich der Ereignisse knapp
einen Monat später - 24. Mai zum 29. Mai,
wo man erkennen kann, dass diese Ausweitung bei
Popasnaja immer mehr dazu geführt hat, dass der
Kessel eingedrückt worden ist. Die Russen dürften
den Kessel für mehrere Wochen nicht geschlossen
haben, weil sie den Vorteil erkannt haben, dass
die Ukrainer immer wieder Nachschub - darunter auch
westliche Waffen - in den Kessel hineingeschoben
haben, wo sie von den Russen leicht zerstört werden
konnten. Dazu gibt es auch einige Videos, wie dieses
eine Video von einer M-777-Batterie,
die von russischer Artillerie angegriffen wird.
Wenn wir dann in den Juni hineinspringen, dann
sehen wir, dass sich langsam zwei Kessel gebildet
haben: Einmal quasi südlich von Sjewjerodonezk und einmal
bei Lyssytschansk, einmal hier in diesem Raum Solote
und nordostwärts davon. Auch hier war es so, dass
die Russen Tag für Tag langsam vorgerückt sind und
der Druck auf die ukrainischen Streitkräfte immer
größer geworden ist. Bis diese gezwungen waren, sich
zurückzuziehen. Schlussendlich war es dann so, dass
die Russen es geschafft haben, was sie in den letzten
Wochen mehrmals versucht haben: Tatsächlich
eine Übersetzstelle über den Siwerskiy Donez
zu errichten und somit von zwei Seiten
gleichzeitig angegriffen haben, was dazu geführt
hat, dass die ukrainische Seite begonnen hat, sich
aus dem Kessel abzusetzen. Dass es dabei ziemlich
hektisch zugegangen ist, zeigt uns das folgende
Video, wo man sieht, dass die ukrainischen Soldaten
zwar nicht ihr schweres Gerät, aber ihr eigenes
Leben zumindest aus dem Kessel retten konnten.
Am 3. Juli 2022 war es dann so weit:
Tatsächlich gelang es den Russen, auch die
zweite Stadt, Lyssytschansk, einzunehmen und hier an
diesem Bild, im Zentrum der Stadt und auch an
den Fahnen erkennbar, haben wir einerseits die
Fahne Russlands, die Erinnerungsfahne an den
großen vaterländischen Krieg (die Fahne, die über dem
Reichstag in Berlin gehisst worden ist) und die Fahne
der Teilrepublik Luhansk. Hier kann man erkennen,
dass sie diesen Sieg natürlich in der gleichen
Art und Weise gefeiert haben wie Mariupol. Die
Frage ist: Wie geht es jetzt weiter? Wenn wir uns jetzt
noch einmal den Donbass ansehen, so erkennen wir,
dass die Ausmaße des Donbass sehr groß sind
bzw. wenn wir weiter zurück in den Westen schauen,
dass hier noch eine große Distanz zu überwinden ist.
Der Kessel von Lyssytschansk und Sjewjerodonezk, der
von den Russen eingenommen worden ist, hatte ein
Ausmaß von circa 40 mal 40 Kilometern, also relativ
klein, wenn man die Größe des gesamten Bereiches
betrachtet. Die Frage ist natürlich: Wie wird sich
der nächste Ansatz der Russen jetzt darstellen?
Wir werden jetzt wieder vier Faktoren hernehmen:
Nämlich das Gelände, die Zeit, Information und
Kraft, um eine kurze Analyse anzustellen. Die erste
Frage nach dem Gelände: Wenn man sich in das
Gelände des Donbass hineinversetzt, so erkennt man,
dass es zwei günstige Verteidigungslinien gibt.
Eine Verteidigungslinie läuft von Siwersk Richtung
Bachmut. Das ist auch jene Linie, wo die ukrainischen
Kräfte aus dem Kessel jetzt zurückgegangen sind.
Die zweite Verteidigungslinie in der Tiefe, die
sich vor allem deswegen günstig darstellt, weil
sie wie eine Perlenkette urbane Räume aneinanderreiht,
geht von Slowjansk, Kramatorsk bis hinunter
nach Tortezk. Auch diese Verteidigungslinie
würde sich für eine Abwehr des weiteren russischen
Angriffes günstig erweisen. Die Frage ist: Wie viele
Kräfte konnten die ukrainische Seite tatsächlich
aus dem Kessel herausziehen? Und wie viele Kräfte
haben sie in der Tiefe jetzt im Einsatz, um
den möglichen Vorstoß der Russen abwehren zu
können? Die zweite Frage ist die der Zeit. Wir
sehen hier ein Bild des Besuches von Sergej
Shoigu in Donbass bei den russischen Truppen.
Auf diesem Bild ist interessant, wir sehen General
Zhidko, das ist der zur Zeit führende
Kommandeur der russischen Truppen im Einsatz, der
Nachfolger von Alexander Dwornikov und er führt
im Prinzip zwei Manövergruppen, einerseits geführt
durch Alexander Lapin und Sergey Surovikin. Dieses
Bild ist deswegen wichtig, denn es zeigt, dass die
Russen eine klare Führungsstruktur haben. Einen
Kommandant über alle russischen Truppen im Raum
beziehungsweise untergeordnete Kommandeure einmal
für den Donbass und einmal für den Süden und den
Osten des Raums. Wenn die russischen Truppen, die
jetzt vorfühlen in Richtung Westen erkennen, dass
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte keine durchgehende
gefestigte Verteidigungslinie haben, dann werden
sie den Erfolg ausnützen und weiter Richtung Westen
ansetzen -  das heißt, es kann also sein, dass es gar
nicht zu einer operativen Pause kommt, sondern dass
die Russen versuchen, den Erfolg der
Schließung des Kessels weiter auszunützen. Die
nächste Frage, wie wir uns stellen müssen ist,
wo und wie erfolgt dieser Ansatz. Es kann also sein,
dass es durchaus einen frontalen Ansatz gibt über
diese zwei Verteidigungslinien, die wir vorher
im Gelände angesprochen haben; es kann aber auch sein
und es spricht einiges dafür, denn es gibt Berichte
von Kräftezusammenziehungen im Raum nördlich des
Donbass, dass man versucht, in der Tiefe diese
Verteidigungslinien zu umfassen. Das wäre wieder ein
weiter Stoß in die Tiefe, der natürlich das Problem
mit sich bringt, möglicher offenen Flanken
aber er würde, wenn die ukrainische Streitkräfte
tatsächlich geschwächt sind, den Russen die
Möglichkeit geben, diese Operationsführung
wesentlich zu verkürzen. Wie es sich tatsächlich
darstellt, werden wir in den nächsten Tagen
und Wochen erleben. Die letzte Frage, die wir uns
stellen müssen, ist das Kräfteverhältnis, das
ganz entscheidend ist für die Einsatzführung
von beiden Seiten. Hier ist interessant, dass wenn
wir auf diesem Bild uns ansehen, das Verhältnis
sich immer mehr zu Gunsten der Russen verschiebt.
Warum? Vor der Schlacht um den Donbass, also vor
knapp zwei Monaten bzw. am Beginn des dritten Monats,
also mit den Vorbereitungsmaßnahmen, war es so,
dass die Ukraine ein Verhältnis hatte von ca.
81 Bataillonsäquivalenten versus 93 auf der
russischen Seite. Diese Zahlen sind im Detail von
den Experten umstritten, aber das ist die Zahl auf
die man sich unisono zu diesem Zeitpunkt
geeinigt hat. Jetzt sieht es so aus, als ob die
russische Seite weiter verstärkt worden ist in
den letzten Wochen um zumindest 15 Bataillonstaktische Gruppen, während auf der anderen Seite
die ukrainische Seite zunehmend abgenützt worden
ist. Das heißt, wir haben also ein Verhältnis von 60
Bataillonsäquivalenten zu 108 Bataillonstaktischen
Gruppen. Natürlich muss man berücksichtigen, dass
beide Seiten Verluste erlitten haben und dass diese
Bataillonsäquivalente möglicherweise nicht
die volle Stärke haben. Aber man sieht, dass die
ukrainische Seite Schwierigkeiten hat, zusätzlicheKräfte heranzuführen und die russische Seite
offensichtlich immer noch aus Russland Kräfte - und nicht nur Material, sondern auch Personal -
nachschieben kann. Die Frage ist: Die Waffensysteme, die bis jetzt geliefert worden sind, haben sie
tatsächlich einen Effekt erzielt? Wir wissen, dassmechanisierte Kräfte, vor allem Kampfpanzer
geliefert von Polen und Tschechien, man nimmt an, dass circa 250 Stück jetzt insgesamt geliefert worden
sind, tatsächlich auf dem Gefechtsfeld eingesetztwerden - jedoch auch erbeutet und zerstört werden.
Interessanter ist der Einsatz der Artillerie. Hierwurden zwar nur wenige Systeme geliefert, aber manerkennt,
dass vor allem der Einsatz des Systems
HIMARS, von dem zumindest vier sich schon im Raum
befinden, aber auch der Einsatz der
weitreichenden Panzerartillerie wie z.B. dieses
polnische System Krab oder die deutsche Panzerhaubitze 2000 sehr wohl einen Effekt erzielen.
Man erkennt das unter anderem daran, dass die deutschePanzerhaubitze 2000 Endphasen-gesteuerte Munition
verschießt, wie diese SMArt 155 die sehr wohl zuspektakulären Erfolgen beitragen kann. Besonders
bemerkenswert ist der Einsatz der amerikanischenHIMARS-Systemes. Dieses System ist ausgestattet mit
einer speziellen Munitionssorte, die offensichtlichbereits erfolgreich vor allem gegen die russischen
Munitionsdepots eingesetzt worden ist. Hiergibt es Indizien dafür, dass es zu Angriffen
auf Munitionsdepots in Russland aber auch inder Ukraine gekommen ist, zum Beispiel bei
Melitopol. Auf diesen Bildern soll man erkennen, dass verschiedene Bestandteile eines bestimmten
Raketentyps tatsächlich darauf hinweisen,
dass das HIMARS-System eingesetzt worden ist.
Hier handelt es sich um das System M31 A1 GMLRS, das offensichtlich im Einsatz verwendet
wird, mit einer Reichweite von knapp 80 Kilometern, um diese russischen Munitionsdepots zu zerstören.
Warum ist die Zerstörung der Munitionsdepots sowichtig? Weil damit die Fähigkeit der russischen
Seite, diesen massiven Artillerie-Einsatz weiter zu nähren, entsprechend verringertwerden würde. Auf dem nächsten Video zeigen wir
Ihnen ganz kurz die Auswirkung eines derartigenAngriffes auf ein russisches Munitionsdepot.
Was wir uns auch noch fragen müssen, ist die Frageder Abnützung. Wir haben das in einigen Videos
auch schon angesprochen. Das Problem ist: Wir habeneinerseits eine taktisch-operative Abnützung auf
dem Gefechtsfeld. Hier war lange Zeit im Unklaren, wie zum Beispiel die Verluste der Ukraine sich
wirklich und tatsächlich darstellen. Und hier istes bemerkenswert, dass einige hohe ukrainische
Offiziere, unter anderem dieser Brigadegeneral, vorkurzem zum Ausdruck gebracht haben, dass sie sehr
wohl sehr schwere Verluste erlitten haben. Wirkönnen das an seinen Zitaten erkennen.
Also insgesamt 50 Prozent Verluste der Streitkräfte, über 1.300 Schützenpanzer, 400 Panzer, 700 Artillerie-
-systeme. Er hat sogar ganz gezielt angesprochen dieWirkung des amerikanischen M777-Systems,
wo er sagt, dass das Problem ist, dass die Batterieoft nur ein oder zwei Schuss an den Feind bringt. Dann aber
sofort vom russischen Gegenfeuer beschossen wirdund es da zu Schäden kommt, die dazu
führen, dass die Geschütze nicht mehr eingesetztwerden können und zurückgeführt werden müssen -
zum Teil nach Polen, um dann dort wieder instandgesetzt zu werden. Das Zweite, viel wichtiger ist
aber die strategische Abnützung unter der die Ukraine zuleiden hat. Auch hier hat der Präsident vor kurzem
gesagt, am 9. Juni, und diese Zahl hat sich bereitserhöht, dass bis jetzt um die 2.600 Marschflugkörper
und ballistische Raketen gegen Ziele in der Ukraineeingesetzt worden sind. Man sagt, dass viele dieser
Raketen möglicherweise ihr Ziel nicht treffen. Die Massetut es, wie uns die Videos, die wir jeden Tag und
jede Nacht sehen, zeigen. Und das Problem ist, dassdie Ukraine hier natürlich massiv abgenützt
wird. Ein Beispiel für massive Luftangriffe
haben wir gesehen am 25. auf den 26. Juni, wo aus
Russland kommend vom belarussischen Staatsgebietaus es zu massivem Einsatz von Marschflugkörpern
in der Ukraine gekommen ist. Unter anderem unterAnwendung dieser Tu-22
Bomber, die hier Marschflugkörper in einer
großen Entfernung gelöst haben, die dann Ziele in der
Ukraine getroffen haben. Solange die Ukrainekeine Fliegerabwehr hat, kann sie sich effektiv
gegen diese Angriffe nicht wehren. Kommen wirnur ganz kurz noch zu den vier Kernproblemen,
die nach wie vor bestehen. Das erste Kernproblemhaben die Ukrainer gelöst. Sie haben die Stadt Kiew,
das politische und militärische Zentrum gehalten. Siehaben auch bis jetzt verhindern können, dass es
zu einem Einsatz von der belarussischen Seite aufukrainisches Staatsgebiet gekommen ist, was sie
aber natürlich daran hindert, die Masse ihrer Kräfteim Osten einzusetzen, weil sie immer Kräfte bereithalten müssen in der Tiefe des Landes. Bis jetztungelöst sind beide Probleme im Süden und im
Osten. Einmal die Problematik im Donbass, wo esjetzt gelungen ist, den Russen diesen 40 mal 40
Kilometer Kessel einzudrücken und die Frageist, ob sie weiter Richtung Westen antreten
werden oder nicht. Und die Situation in Cherson, diesich verheerend darstellt, weil hier die Russen
es bereits geschafft haben, auf die andere Seitedes Dnjepr überzugehen und theoretisch damit die
Möglichkeit haben, im Frühjahr - also nach dem Winter -von hier aus nach Odessa oder in
den zentralen Raum der Ukraine vorzustoßen. Daserscheint momentan unwahrscheinlich, kann sich
aber natürlich in einigen Monaten ändern. Vor allemin der Zeit des Winters, wo die Ukraine gefordert
ist, im Winter zu überleben, während die russischeSeite sich konsolidieren kann. Schauen wir uns ganz
kurz die eroberten Gebiete an, so erkennen wir, dass der Oblast Cherson zu 94 Prozent in Hand
der Russen ist. Mykolajiw ist mit Masse noch in Hand
der Ukraine, in Saporischschja sind 75 Prozent des Oblasts
in russischer Hand. In Charkiw 67 Prozent inukrainischer Hand, während in Luhansk vor kurzem
verkündet worden ist, vor einigen Tagen, die 100-prozentige Einnahme dieses Oblasts. Es scheint
daher logisch zu sein, dass das nächste Ziel der Russen sein wird, auch den zweiten Oblast, nämlich
Donezk, einzunehmen. Und hier sehen wir, dassnoch circa 46 Prozent des Gebietes fehlen im
Donbass, um diesen Oblast zur Gänze aus russischerDiktion "befreien" zu können. Die Frage ist also: Wie
wird sich die Front in den nächsten Wochen und Monatendarstellen? Und es scheint sehr wahrscheinlich, dass
vor allem der Donbass, aber auch der Raum Chersoneine entsprechende Bedeutung haben wird. Der Winter
hat seine ganz wichtige Bedeutung, denn bis zum
Ende des Sommers werden beide Seiten versuchen,
auf dem Gefechtsfeld eine Entscheidung zu ihren
Gunsten herbeizuführen. Wenn das nicht gelingt,
kommt der Winter. Der Winter wird die Kampfhandlungen zum
Erliegen bringen. Das Problem der Ukraine wird sein,
dass sie vor allem mit ihrer Bevölkerung den
Winter überleben muss. 35 Millionen Ukrainer müssen
durch den Winter gebracht werden. Das Problem ist,
dass durch die Inbesitznahme von 24 Prozent des
Staatsgebiets durch die Russen bereits 80 Prozent
der Wertschöpfung sich in russischer Hand befindet.
Wenn es die Russen tatsächlich schaffen sollten,
im Sommer des nächsten Jahres oder im Frühjahr
Richtung Odessa anzutreten, wäre diese Zahl
sogar noch höher, circa 90 bis 95 Prozent.
Auch die Weizenanbaugebiete, und hier auch zum
Beispiel der Winterweizen, befinden sich
mit Masse im Süden und im Osten des Landes.
Der Weizenexport war zu 45 Prozent für das ukrainische BIP verantwortlich, das heißt, die Ukraine hat das
Problem, dass sie ohne massive Unterstützung des
Westens nicht den Winter übersteht, aber auch nicht
in der Lage ist, weiter den Kampf gegen Russland zu
führen. Unsere Präsentationen sind so objektiv
wie möglich, eine objektive Bewertung ist die
Grundlage jedes klaren Lagebildes. Heute, am Ende,
möchte ich eine Ausnahme machen. Letztes Jahr hatte
ich die Ehre, das österreichische Kontingent im
Kosovo als Kontingentskommandant führen zu dürfen.
In meiner internationalen Funktion war ich
im Rahmen der Nato-geführten Mission KFOR
der Kommandant der Joint Logistics Support Group.
In dieser Funktion hatte ich auch 50 ukrainische
Soldaten unter meinem Kommando, darunter drei
Offiziere. Einer dieser drei Offiziere, ein
treuer Kamerad und guter Freund, Kyrylo Hubanov, ist im Alter von 26 Jahren am 10. Juni im
Rahmen der Schlacht im Donbass gefallen. An
dieser Stelle schlägt die Freundschaft die
Neutralität und es ist mir ein persönliches
Anliegen, seiner Person zu gedenken und ihm zu
Ehren dieses Bild zu zeigen. Damit bin ich
am Ende meiner Präsentation und sage "Auf Wiederschaun!".